تعرضت قريه نوفا كالجوفكا والتي تقع في
المنطقه الغربيه من المدينه لضربات
صاروخيه هذا ما تحدث عنه عمده المدينه قبل
نحو دقائق من الان هناك مناطق اخرى طبعا
في شبيكنا احمد تتعرض لضربات للمره
الثالثه على التوالي قريه بورم ايضا تنال
ضربات خلال الساعات الاخيره اليوم طبعا هي
الارقام كبيره اذا ما تم مقارنتها
بالمراحل السابقه التي عاشتها المدينه
خلال مرحله الصراع في الخريف الماضي عندما
كنا نتواجد هنا في هذه النقطه احمد في
مركز المدينه كانت طبعا تعمل انظمه الدفاع
الجوي بكثره في سماء المدينه في المركز
طبعا لكن اليوم الوضع تغير نوعا ما نلاحظ
نقص لعنصر الشباب في شوارع المدينه نلاحظ
ان الاعمال التجاريه انخفضت بشكل كبير
وهذا الشيء طبعا لما المناطق في ضواحي
المدينه لابد من لفت الانتباه بلا ان في
المنطقه الغربيه من المدينه احمد في شبكنا
تحديدا وفي المناطق المجاوره لها تتعرض
تلك المناطق لضربات مختلفه لابد من
التوضيح بان خط الحدود الفاصل بين اقليم
بيل جراند والاراضي الاوكرانيه يمتد
لقرابه 400 كيلومتر لذلك هذا العدد الكبير
الذي يصل خلال الاربع والعشرين ساعه
الماضي الى 220 ضربه هو في مناطق مختلفه
لكن التركيز على المناطق الغربيه الاقرب
الى مقاطعات خاصه
ما الذي تمثل هذه المدينه
ما الذي تمثله هذه المدينه حتى يتم
استهدافها واختيارها على قيمه الاهداف
الاوكرانيه هل من رمزيه معينه لها
طبعا احمد يعني هذه المدينه هي الاقرب
للاراضي الاوكرانيه يعني تقع مباشره
ضواحيها على الشريط الحدودي الفاصل
المتاخم بين البلدين هذه المدينه فيها
تكتل عسكري كبير الان من قبل الجانب
الروسي يعني البعض سماها بالسكنه العسكريه
نوعا ما طبعا لوجود المعدات الثقيله كانت
حكومه المدينه تحدثت عن توافد المئات خلال
الايام الماضيه بعد محاوله اقتحام ضواحيها
من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه لذلك طبعا هي
وجهه كما يتحدث عمده المدينه للقذائف
الصاروخيه المدفعيه المسيرات والعبوات
الناسفه التي تقوم بالقائها هذه المسيرات
نسمع في مركز المدينه بين الفينه والاخرى
عمل بعض انظمه الدفاع الجوي واستهدافها
لبعض الضربات لكن معظمها هو على اطراف
المدينه وليس في مركزها نقطه هامه طبعا في
التحول بوضع المدينه احمد لاحظناها بشكل
واضح بان بيلغراد يعني قبل سته اشهر لم
تقم باجلاء سكانها ولا سكان المناطق
الحدوديه الى نقاط مختلفه لكنها اليوم
قامت بانشاء مراكز لاستقبال اللاجئين
مؤقته كما تسميها حكومه المدينه هي تبعد
قرابه 200 كيلو متر عن هذه المدينه نحو
العمق في الداخل الروسي وقامت بنقل السكان
من الضواحي الى تلك المناطق لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات